hanging here some big hold on dear
always want to say that they spell ver
and I will be Michelle but realizes but
I'm retired extension I didn't get fired
I didn't quit at his old thing this is a
required about evaluation form
feel silly I wanted to talk just a few
minutes and I appreciate the opportunity
of that Marsha gave me because when I
heard about this conference I've been
reading about for several years and I
decided what the heck I'm just going to
drive up and see what y'all are doing
see if we can do it back home I realize
yeah we can do it but we don't want to
have a different kind of grass down
there it runs it doesn't stay in one
place and so we have to do more than
buying stuff so I enjoyed watching them
do the madea than the woven stop by the
way I real van it into what they call
deconstructionism you know what that is
taking complicated things and making a
real simple you know and what they're
doing over and under in and out that's
all weavings about any questions I know
that they can stroke well I have a lot
of what we call demotivators they use a
lot since our return I don't have to be
cheerful anymore I don't be nice anymore
okay i started the Master Gardener
program is a center but they ran me off
from a quick because a lot of those
people don't understand gardening they
want to be for Nicole system is real
left brain left brain is how do you do
it what's the quickest way what's the
most efficient how do we get the most
how do we keep this from happening you
know objective stuff horticulture is all
about pruning roses at a quarter of an
inch above an outward facing five
who's ever heard that before hey bro you
can prune roses with cherry bombs and
still fun anybody ever ever yo girl Rosa
share or is it out via up here okay we
had my great-grandmother girls well we
have those in the south and no drunk
driver ran over Althea and it's crowded
right back out of kept home polygamy's
I'm thinking you can prove stuff with
pickup trucks when I talk about
directional pruning and Paula Deen is
handing back and all this stuff I talk
Master Gardener I feel a little silly as
a gardener I give another example of a
lift rate versus right brain any
composters here bouncer I'm hardcore
I've got a trump post to ban system I
trend my particle sizes I bio activated
i inoculated I get my carbon-nitrogen
ratio right I'm turned into air into
keep it moist I made compost from start
to finish one time in three weeks flat
rodale press says you can do it in three
weeks I was going to try to do in 20
days couldn't do it but me pretty weak
to students I work but a low by airaid
to turn it every day I kept more I got
it after 167 degrees
and you know what nobody can there's not
a race to compost another time for the
club this is since I realized only tools
for fun posing just two rules for
composting number one stop throwing that
stuff away number two pile it up
somewhere just all the leaf pile if you
want to make it nice and neat like with
a being [ __ ] are 15 leaf pile that's
the construction this I real bad about
that when i started brought something
back to this truck years and years ago
and i think it was Mark Twain he would
talk about the dog that could dance
nothing that could dance well but then
to dance at all okay and so I got tired
of people now that I'm retired I can use
this word whining I got tired of people
whining about gardening I don't have
turned the guard I real the place a
guard now the deconstructionism who's
got a water garden here if I have water
garden film a fun folks a lot of people
don't have it because it looks
complicated if you can grow a focus and
a cup of coffee you've got all this
everything is a variation that very
simple and I use this approach want to
talk to Master Gardener house long times
and so I also have a walk i'll post as
soon as you say carbonizing the ratio
your audience's eyes glaze over because
scary is daunting there's a woman who
write for horticultural magazine on the
wrote a book called the undaunted
gardener y'all seen their first oh weird
aunt is we're not dumb ok so I started
on supper back to the truck I start out
with a bag of potting soil it's the
pillow garden concept we've got a bag of
pot I saw to cut three little X holes
put some cosmic code in it no it's not
organic I use also too and I put a
pepper tomato and apparently Madagascar
Carolyn and I real peppers and tomatoes
in fear away from the back of my pickup
truck that folks because the 105 degrees
in is a city last week and three in the
morning it cool
maybe
why driving can fall a second
I grew the peppermint tomato the fair
way to go back to prove that anybody
keep garden all you need is to get
started everything is a simple
variational simple simple thing that you
can do that anybody takes a look at that
Thanks immediately well I can do better
than that I think it's okay that's the
point do it you know don't sit around
thinking about it and we we decide the
left brain of horticulture is different
from the right frame of guarding okay
Gardner's do things to the pure love of
it left brain will measure the side of
them of a box three times make sure it's
right okay talk about coloring outside
the box that brain will measure the box
okay how many square feet it is light
brain doesn't know this a box okay think
we just go right through it we decided
that gardeners have right now any master
gardeners here okay well this is not
stepping into taught by Cornell and
hence paid or an issue or any place Mike
then they can teach you how to do stuff
okay how to do it right how to do it
well here's a little thing that we came
up with with the right brain of
gardening we decided the gardener's can
you came up the gardener's bill of
rights here interview of them and these
are things the horticulturist will not
understand never will camera okay one is
a gardener shall have the right to as
many wind chimes as we can focus all
right what coaches doesn't get that by
the way I've got a win-win job back when
I got out of highway us an ice cream
truck home free anybody here from all
over the West's on their earrings I
think the Erie Pennsylvania today and I
got two inches of rain which I years old
I of knockout road
what's the point the point is I just got
engaged with my guard with the world I
put the world you know by or not a
measure the rain in a rain and a rain
gauge oh you're doing several things the
rainy days in my home garden is out back
to get to the rain gauge I have to walk
out the door across the deck down some
steps ups and flags down to walk through
the ball well the house for the format
house the wooden decks to the rock class
of the law
I feel any one of those things to the
bottom of my feet I feel thing to the
bottom of my feet watch at the main gate
intellectually connected with the world
I know how much you rain and I thought
I don't want to lose it the airport
George Louis to touch things I've spell
things felt things out heard things I
saw things all my senses are engaged
chicken to scoop them playing game per
month or works just as well so whatever
it takes to get us outside the garden
set up otherwise gardeners shall have
the right to mispronounce lately anybody
here say herb with an H you know that
had a French the French say earn the
British say her what are we gonna do
folks i'm from the south i pronounced
with an eight you know i got an 8 10
have editors who changed my herb garden
to my herb dark I say I grow a herb
called what they'll change to an FIR in
a really year days probably i'm one of
the national director the garden Writers
Association of America and if all joined
in that day of the Lord lighter I wanted
to make this woman back here they Marsha
who want a very prestigious national
award
publication on children's garden bacon
Cornell I guess semi-automatic you as
well as I came up to see what was going
on this is my fourth trip to this campus
and all four times I drew the gardener
she'll have a right to know grass at all
except maybe a little patch Elaine you
back to one superclass the corner shall
have the right to plant any color flower
next to any color flower they clash yeah
you have a premium designer one time
tell me that pink and orange don't go
together I'm thinking I hope he never
seen a purple coneflower whatever design
those are scattered across New York must
they had poor things